hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
going to be my Batman V Superman
Ultimate Edition video with Easter eggs
so just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the movie yet well what the
hell is the Ultimate Edition how is it
different from the theatrical cut well
it's just an extra 30 minutes of footage
that really broaden the context of each
of the characters storylines so if you
were confused about why Lex Luthor
seemed to have some crazy plan that
developed overnight you weren't sure
about his motivations he gets more story
in this longer cut the same thing
happens with Lois Lane there's a lot
more visual Easter eggs for DC Comics as
well as ex Snyder's previous films like
Watchmen although actually technically
Watchmen is now part of the main DC
canon in the comics because of what's
going on during rebirth but that's like
a completely separate comic book thing
the takeaway really is that all this
extra stuff won't change your original
opinion about the film if you didn't
like it for thematic reasons if you
didn't like the idea of them
deconstructing Batman and Superman this
longer cut of the film isn't going to
change that opinion but it will clear up
confusion over certain story points so I
guess it makes the film better in that
sense and if you really do like the
really extreme long cuts of the film
with extra footage thrown in if you're
really big geek for like all the
different editions of the Blade Runner
movie like all the different cuts of
that it's not quite the same as that I
would argue that like the last kind of
the Blade Runner film there's like 10
different cuts of that movie the last
cut of that film is pretty amazing this
isn't like that but it is still pretty
cool especially if your big DC comics
fan so here are a couple Easter eggs
that were in the Ultimate Edition that
you did not see in the theatrical cut
there's a scene in a police car where
someone references Delta charlie 27 as
in DC 27 which was Detective Comics 27
Batman's first appearance in the comics
at the end of the film when Lex Luthor's
being put in prison there's actually a
really fun Easter Egg for Superman so in
the new Ultimate Edition his prisoner
number is AC 23 1940 which is the first
appearance of Superman Action Comics
number 23 in 1940 but the fun thing is
is that in the theatrical cut Lex
Luthor's prisoner number was tk-421
which is a Star Wars reference so in
both cuts of the film Lex Luthor's
prisoner number is an Easter egg it's
just that they change it to more
Superman DC Comics centric one in the
longer version of the film there's a big
Jimmy
Olsson easter egg so this character here
is playing Jimmy Olsen in the movie but
he gets killed off immediately so a lot
of people were like wait a minute
the Zack Snyder just killed Jimmy Olsen
that's a pretty big deal so they took
his name out of the theatrical cut you
never really hear that his name is Jimmy
Olsen Zack Snyder confirmed it after the
movie came out in the Ultimate Edition
he actually introduces himself to Lois
Lane as Jimmy Olsen in they referenced
talent which in the new 52 was court of
owls so you have a little bit of court
of owls Batman stuff happening there's
more Aquaman stuff going on there's this
secondary news reporter character who's
part of the Aquaman comics her name is
kahi Nazira they just go into her story
a little bit more so it's like you know
they're building context for more of
these Justice League characters as
opposed to like the really quick scene
that they got on the hard drive speaking
of cyborg flash stuff we learned that
STAR Labs is located in Metropolis so it
looks like they're not going to be
flying all over the United States to
talk to each other when it gets to
Justice League there are two big
watchmen references there's the end is
nigh on a billboard here which is like a
Rorschach sign that he carries around
drink Watchmen and then during Batman
it's Superman's fight when Batman has
the armor on they go down this staircase
there's this graffiti here that says who
watches the Watchers which is just a
reference to who watches the Watchmen so
a lot of watchmen a lot of DC comics
stuff there in the Ultimate Edition that
you didn't see in the theatrical cut we
do see ace chemicals but I think that we
saw that in the theatrical cut too so I
don't think that that was changed for
the Ultimate Edition but let me know
what you guys think if you have seen the
Ultimate Edition let me know what you
thought about the extra footage it
really just builds out the rest of the
characters stories there's a little more
Justice League set up creates more
context for the DC movie universe but I
don't think it necessarily changes the
film completely you can kind of
understand why they cut some of this
stuff out like it wasn't absolutely
necessary to tell the story that they
were telling but some really cool
Justice League stuff so if you guys
didn't hear a bunch of people got to go
to the set of Justice League I talked
about it a little bit in one of my
previous videos everyone was really
happy with what they saw the costumes
have changed a little bit
Batman is going to get a whole bunch of
new toys he has two new suits they look
a little bit more hardcore a little more
steampunky he's going to be fighting the
forces of apocalypse so of course he's
going to need better toys but if you
haven't seen it check it out if you buy
it on iTunes like digitally I think it's
about 20 dollars but the blu-ray is
about $25
so you know just depends on like which
format you like the best so if you
really like the film and you want this
extra footage and a lot of the bonus
content there's some behind the scenes
stuff like them building the Batcave
that's about twenty-five dollars for the
blu-ray you can get the iTunes digital
download if you want for about twenty
bucks if you don't get to say every
structure is actually floating it's a
Dodge the very low footprint on the cave
it's maybe hanging but there is no big
pillar that seems to be floating in the
air
this is Bruce Wayne's lab we're actually
controlling it from here a lot of times
actors are staring at green screens and
trying to act out what scene and the
story is about but we help provide a
live experience that really helps the
director its inform where an actor can
react to in terms of the action on the
scene this is men station this is where
he works most of the time the only thing
that actually touches the wand is a
chair so actually I'll say new round of
the giveaway starts now a $20 Amazon
gift card you can use it to buy the
blu-ray you can use to buy whatever you
want so all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video I'll announce the winner when
I post my next DC video so what's going
to happen is is they just announced tom
Felton from Harry Potter is going to be
on the flash season 3 he'll be something
of an antagonist I have a couple ideas
for characters I think that he could be
playing I do think that he's playing a
comic book character but they gave him a
name that is not from DC Comics I think
that's just a big misdirect so I'll
explain when I post that later tonight
so everybody just hold the door Wonder
Woman style till I post that video why
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to learn what's going on with
DC comics rebirth and the flash in the
comics and you can click here to learn a
little bit more about what's going on
with the flash movie how that's going to
be different from a flash TV show so
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight